so we're gonna twist here and that
didn't sound good you know hey everyone
I'm Joe today I am testing out pasta
gadgets we have several different pasta
gadgets we found from all over the
Internet I'll be checking out these
gadgets based on these three criteria if
they make the process easier how well
they work and are they a good value for
the price I love pasta
let's get started we have a stainless
steel pressure pasta surface machine it
did come with free delivery this big ol
heavy-duty countertop pasta extruder the
ravioli pasta stamps plus the stamp cost
the stamp this little guy here I am
incredibly excited about little singing
floating pasta timer mr. al dente
Restaurant cheese grater here for
grating cheese for the pasta there's
pictures of pasta on it and last but not
least we have a new and improved I use
strainer we have all of our gadgets here
now all we need is the pasta dough and
we can get to work all right we have
unboxed our pasta extruder here put this
together we're gonna turn it on we're on
kind of makes me a little nervous
dealing with all this plastic normally I
know metal is better oh we got to add
flour so we're going to start there I
have a mix of eggs and water start mix
now this is where I slowly add my liquid
kind of do 5050 here that is what the
recommended dosage is on the box
I think the timer in here says it only
takes two minutes an extruder here what
it does is uses pressure to force the
dough through these different dyes and
different shapes in order to make pasta
says it can make up to a pound and a
half know about a pound is good for two
to four people in theory dried boxed
pasta is usually better than anything
you can make it home it turned off oh it
looks like we're extruding the dough
inside actually looks pretty good and
don't know if it's okay at this rate
we'll have spaghetti by tomorrow it's
like a little baby
spaghetti coming out into the world for
the very first time actually has texture
on it which is a good thing I'm gonna
take a little bit of semolina flour here
and give it a little dust this and that
actually looks pretty promising I am
very impressed by this entire machine
the question is is this better than just
buying dr box of pasta you ought to have
this whole machine you have to wash it
and you box the spaghetti is only about
a dollar the dough itself seems a little
delicate and fragile I'm not sure if
it's gonna hold up when we go to boil it
I'm very curious to see how these are
gonna cook up now we're onto the
handheld old-fashioned version of
extruding pasta this is called a Torchio
it's made by twisting the top and you're
forcing the dough through the bottom
much like the extruder we're just using
but uh handheld the price of the real
one is four or five hundred dollars
probably about twice twice as big like
this and hangs over the edge of the
table so that way you're like extruding
and you have these big turning things
screw the bottom on so we're gonna twist
here
and that didn't sound good we just
scored it off the bottom I heard a loud
snap let's unwind take two Rolly nope
maybe I was doing it backwards and we
got another pop it's falling apart the
dough is creating too much pressure
inside of the die looks like this guy's
a bust I don't think that's gonna work
we're going to test out the pasta we had
extruded with our countertop extruder so
let's see if it holds when we cook it
and we're going ahead and drop this into
our water give it a little stir and
break up the nest I have some tomato
sauce we're just gonna get started I'm
gonna pull one out give it a little
taste test I'm just about al dente there
we're gonna go up here into our tomato
pull all of our noodles out of the hot
tub for the most part they held together
it's now falling apart we got a nice
good noodle pull their time gonna try
these out now I have another pasta
gadget here my cheese grater and a break
off a piece slide it inside and that
goes there and oh my G
look at that cheese grater worked great
you did what should kept it nice and
easy you twirl it and swirl it and enjoy
it I'm very happy with this we're gonna
come back test out our strainer test out
our timer with some dry pasta from a box
[Music]
well we have al dente this guy supposed
to sing to me at different intervals has
four different melodies depending on the
four different cook points of al dente
you want to hit that's amore
The Godfather theme tarantella
napolitana and the prisoners choir he
goes into the water pot with the dried
pasta so this is not a regular timer I
don't know how this works some sort of
Witchcraft and Wizardry this is kind of
one of those magical moments well go two
handfuls of pasta we're gonna go mr. al
dente into the water let's see what
happens that's amore he's dancing now
we're just waiting for him to sing all
of my years of culinary and cooking
experience
I am completely forgetting about and
simply relying only on al dente al dente
first name a last name dente
I think we're all
[Music]
that's amore we're gonna pull out one
noodle okay very undercooked but maybe
that's a fresh pasta the timer first
round done he's supposed to sing again
we're hanging out in the kitchen
let's say we're a little more than
halfway on the cook that next timer
might actually be perfect I don't
understand why they don't make like cell
phones out of this where you could just
drop it into a pot of boiling water if
you're not a pasta pro I mean I think
this could actually be useful at the
very least it just reminds you to check
the water and you're testing the pasta
that's al dente
macer dente you nailed it next pasta
tool here this is like a silicone
strainer of sorts that clamps onto the
pot that goes there and then we're gonna
try this pouring motion we got a little
bit of leakage in the back but it's it's
catching all the pasta oh wow that
actually works pretty well kind of goes
against you know what I would normally
do because I like the pasta water I feel
like you need that with the sauce this
is small compact and I mean it does does
the job sounds like his innards are
still working Thank You al dente I could
not have done it without you
we have this box set of ravioli molds I
have my pasta sheets I have a cheese
filling a little bit of spinach period
in here in my bag we'll pipe filling
into each of these I was like a little
spritz of water then we have our other
sheet we're going to place on top and
then we should be able to roll right
down oh we got a little excess that's
okay
in theory with force that should cut our
shapes too you can see it kind of
working then if we pop it out we have
our shapes they didn't cut all the way
in the center but we have this other
tool here which actually might work out
to our advantage
pretty easy pretty painless they got a
good way to them the filling held up
there sealed and we have all of our
little raviolis we'll go and try the
traditional way that I have always done
it they feel really light and flimsy so
I have a sheet of pasta I have my
filling
always like to get a little gauge we
have our top sheet lay over and we have
our stamp
see to me I feel like this is the way to
do it maybe you have a little bit of
waste but you could always roll this out
reuse it get another sheet out of it the
end of the day you cook all of these up
have delicious pasta in minutes probably
won't stand up to work in a restaurant
but for casual pasta making pretty good
bargain alright we've tested out all
these pasta gadgets that we found it's
time to break down my final thoughts
tabletop counter version of extruding
pasta who liked the way this worked it
takes up quite a bit of space it's not
very fast but if you're looking for an
extruder how much does this cost one
hundred and fifty dollars to me that's a
little pricey I'm gonna give it a three
out of five just because it did a good
job hand-held extruder this did not hold
up could not review it essentially how
much did that cost twenty dollars a lot
of times you get what you pay for I
believe in this case that is true I'm
gonna give that a zero because it didn't
work
next we had our cheese grater for pasta
garnishes and grating cheese
accoutrements this worked wonderfully
it's like when you're at your favorite
super classy Italian restaurant and they
come over and they ask you to say when
when you're getting your cheese on top
and then you kind of feel like that
person that never wants to say when the
pile just keeps getting bigger and your
way is that just me
this worked really well how much does it
cost $17 I think that's a little too
much for a tool like this that doesn't
really hold a big piece of cheese two
and a half two and a half just cuz I
don't see the value for $17 and a cheese
grater like that
I'll dent a the singing pasta timer I
was blown away by this
it's next level Dark Arts but how much
did this cost
twenty dollars for al dente I don't
think the values there for the money you
could definitely get a kitchen timer
definitely not worth twenty dollars but
perhaps is like one of those like
holiday gag gifts or like a birthday
present for someone you only kind of
like we give this a 3 out of 5 next our
silicon strainer how much does this cost
$11 seems like a pretty good deal
takes up less space if you have a tiny
kitchen than a big colander
it held a whole pot of pasta stirring
the water no problem I'm gonna say four
four out of five on this one
finally our ravioli tools here ravioli
trays the first time I've used these
they could have done better I'm sure
they get easier the more you use them
$40 I think that's that's probably a
pretty good deal make a lot of raviolis
really fast I'd give that I give that a
four and then these stamp tools they're
just inexpensively made they're not
sturdy they're not heavy-duty but they
could get the job done for small amounts
of pasta these costs $17 that sounds
about right
I'm not upset with that price at all
seventeen bucks I mean four out of five
it's not not a bad option there but I
think my favorite except for the price
is our little singing friend al dente if
you want to check out any of these
gadgets we use today all the links are
in the description below that's it for
today reviewed all of these pasta
gadgets we found on the Internet thanks
for sticking around if you guys have any
other gadgets you want me to review
please leave a comment down below or if
you want to see some next-level
pasta-making check me out on instagram
chef Joe dots asto thanks